yo creo que Juan no se habla del rey del
pueblo eso es un poco
como se decía de Daiana la princesa del
pueblo
estas cosas son frasecitas El poder del
Rey está muy limitado él como príncipe
de galas se opinaba en muchas cosas era
muy presente le gustaba obviamente todas
las gestiones desde mucho tiempo de la
gestión del ecológicas y es importante
que él tenga esta especie de de
identidad ecológica que pueden seguir
pero lo que él puede hacer aún cuando la
cuestión de la unidad de Gran Bretaña o
del Reino Unido depende mucho de la
situación política en el país él no
tiene el poder Él no puede hacer un
discurso oficial importante sin que sea
aprobado o a un escrito en el Downey el
problema en Inglaterra en este ambiente
es que el el los ingleses están
totalmente
de estos gobiernos que han tenido los
cinco primer ministros que han sido un
desastre tras otro
fueron engañados con el voto de brexit
ahora es tan apenados de eso la
inflación como su corresponsal hablaba
huelgas por todos lados Entonces es un
poco un ambiente
amargo en qué en que la idea de tener
una enorme fiesta de coronación que
parece que que se gasta mucho dinero
provoca inevitablemente esas reacciones
la gente sabe por qué se está gastando
dinero y nuestros impuestos y todo eso
es una reacción normal pero sí Alan en
ese en ese orden de ideas con lo que
usted nos explica con esta inestabilidad
política tal vez tener una monarquía
sólida le da esas garantías a los
ciudadanos británicos de estabilidad lo
que están pidiendo en este momento para
su país puede que la economía no vaya
muy bien pero por lo menos hay una
institución sólida dentro de todo el
panorama y es la monarquía desde su
punto de vista qué tan sólida está
entonces a partir de este capítulo que
empezamos a escribir hoy y qué tan
sólido está también la común web la
mancomunidad hay muchos países que han
mostrado su interés por iniciar procesos
para alejarse del Reino Unido pero está
sólida
Yo creo que la monarquía británica está
sólida la relación con las ex colonias
en el es un es un proceso
en Vía de cambiar no lo que lo que ha
pasado últimamente en todo el mundo en
los medios sociales lo que se puede
decir hay una especie de Tal vez desde
Black lives mata está abierto mucho
entonces la cuestión de la esclavitud
por ejemplo de repente en Inglaterra
se estás preguntando a las instituciones
a las universidades a las grandes
familias y a la familia real se hicieron
ricos gracias a los esclavos y estas
preguntas dan eco en las ex colonias
sobre todo del Caribe No tanto de África
porque no fueron participes de eso
Entonces estos temas están en el aire
este de dónde vino todo este dinero de
la esclavitud y y este Esta es los dos
tabloides agarren eso los medios
sociales no es el mundo Que conoció la
reina la reina era un un ícono un poco
protegido por el tiempo y por su edad y
ahora Carlos inevitablemente porque
también su vida su familia los con la
princesa sus hijos todas estas cosas dan
un ambiente mucho más agitado y muchos
más dado él es más vulnerable en este
sentido a crítica yo creo que en los
últimos meses Ha logrado crecer como
símbolo
monático es decir no también como
persona puede decir pero él ha esperado
tanto para ese momento y yo creo que
Honestamente te empieza a agarrar un
símbolo entonces estas preguntas cómo le
preguntaban de de la revolución francesa
y él decía demasiado temprano entonces
yo creo que hay que esperar Yo tengo
cierta confianza que él va a tener una
posición de de respeto
no no va a ser populista la idea del del
de que tiene que mantener la distancia
vive la monarquía británica vive por su
misterio por sus secretos por por los
ritos que hemos visto hoy que nadie no
todo el mundo entiende Cuál era el el el
símbolo aunque fue explicado en la
televisión entonces hay que mantener un
misterio una distancia